I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah. Everyone, we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess. For your next
adventure, for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories.
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. We have a special guest today in the studio. Yes. It's my possible cousin. Yes. Clark Duke.
That's right. Joining us cousin, Clark Duke. That's right. Joining us today is Clark Duke, who played Clark Green on The Office. He joined the show in season nine, episode one, titled New Guys. Clark Green is the new customer service representative at the Scranton branch of Dunder Mifflin. And yes, Angela, a possible cousin of yours.
We'll get to that with him. We did speak about it in more detail. I love this little tangent. But first, here's a little bit about Clark Duke. He is an actor, writer, director, producer. He is originally from Arkansas. How cool is this? When he was in college, Clark created, wrote, directed, and produced the web series Clark and Michael with his friend Michael Cera, in which he plays a fictional version of himself. In our conversation with him, he talks a lot about how that project that he did, that was his college thesis, actually, really informed his role on The Office. Yes.
Yeah. Now listen, you guys might know Clark from his other acting roles in Greek, Superbad, Sex Drive, A Thousand Words, Kick Ass 1 and 2, Hot Tub Time Machine 1 and 2, Bad Moms, Identity Theft, and I'm Dying Up Here, which he stars in with Jake Lacey. He is also a writer and director.
He wrote, directed, and starred in the feature film Arkansas and the upcoming Strange Hold, which reunites him with Jake Lacey. And of course, we all know him from The Office and he joins us in the studio today to talk about his time on The Office, plus so much more. But before we play his interview, I think we need to revisit some fan favorite moments
of Clark. According to fans, this is one of the best one-liners Clark ever said on the show. It's from Moving On, part one. Man, that seemed like it, but this really helped. So thank you. I'll give you $100 to wear that sweater to work tomorrow. Oh yeah. Oh yeah, that was so funny.
That's right. This is when Andy is starting to put together that maybe Aaron is seeing someone. Yes, and maybe she gave his sweater to this new person who is Pete. Yeah. Yes. Well, other fans wrote in to say that they love this bit of Clark sass to Jim in Live in the Dream. We talk about this in our interview with Clark.
Here it is. Oh, Clark. I'm actually here today. Surprise! So I was wondering if maybe I could have my desk back. Right. Yeah, but you know, I've actually been working pretty hard here on a daily basis, so I kind of feel like I've earned this.
I mean, you know? Totally have. You have earned it. But maybe I could be with my wife. That's kind of the whole reason why I'm here. Right. Well, I'm here to sell paper. Burn.
Yes, that is my personal fave. Well, we both have a lot of favorite Clark moments and it's so fun to talk to him about it all. Yes, I think he also may have my favorite call sheet questions answers yet. They were- Like, stay tuned for his call sheet questions is all I have to say. Absolutely. I mean call sheet question number one. Wowzers.
Wowzers. Well, let's take a break and when we come back, it's our interview with Clark Duke. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. And this month, BetterHelp is giving you the biggest discount on starting therapy that they have ever offered on our show, with 90% off your first week. So here's how it works. With BetterHelp, you can pay a flat fee for weekly sessions, and that's going to save you big time on cost and time because therapy should feel accessible and with online therapy you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over
30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and has served over 5 million people globally. And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Your well-being is worth it. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 90% off your I'm Jordan Robinson, host of the new podcast, The Women's Hoop Show. Each episode, I'll be joined by a rotating group of women's basketball experts to talk
WNBA, college hoops, the new Unrivaled League, and the shifting landscape of the sport. The game is growing and so are we. Listen to and follow the Women's Hoop Show and Odyssey podcast available now for free on the Odyssey app or wherever you get your podcasts. ["Women's Hoop Show and Odyssey"] ["Women's Hoop Show and Odyssey"] Hello! Hi! How are you? I'm great! Welcome! Thank you! It's so great to be here. It's nice to see you guys. It's really nice to see you. Besides the Christmas cards. I know.
Yeah. I love getting your mom's Christmas card. We haven't done one in a while. It's because it's like you got to plan it in like June. I June. But I got one. I had it. I taped it up in the dining room. Walked past your family. But we didn't do like a full shoot, you know? No. Like a planned photo shoot. Yeah, but you need to tell your mom she needs to get back on it because she slacked off last year. I agree. Could you guys please share with people how this Christmas card thing came about. It's because you're maybe like distant relatives, right? This is our joke. Okay, so we were chatting on set one day and I was like, wait a second.
We have a lot of the same family names. And then you're from North Carolina. There's this lore that my family's from North Carolina. I mean, are we related? Well, you probably are if they're actually from North Carolina, like confirmed, yeah. I don't know, guys. I could be sitting across from my eighth cousin
twice removed. Well, you're family enough to send a Christmas card every year, even after all these years. I thought at first you meant like the history of like Christmas cards in general, and I was like, I have no idea. I know, I wanna Google that. I know I want to Google that. I know.
You've put that in my head. Yeah. All right, cousin, let's get to it. Let's kick things off with the question we ask everybody. The first question, how did you get your job on the office? So I met Greg Daniels. I forget what year, it was a few, at least a couple years or a few years before I got on The Office and he was making a different show.
And I don't remember if the show, anyway, I ended up not doing that show because it just wasn't for me. But I like Greg so much and I like the office very much, obviously. And then just kind of years later, out of the blue, I got my manager called me one day and said like, basically like Greg wanted to know if he would be interested in like joining the cast of The Office. And I was like, well, yeah, that would be great. Because I mean, for me, I went to film school at Loyola Marymount out here in LA. And my thesis project was an mockumentary called Clark and Michael, me and Michael Cera. And our main influence was two things.
It was this thing called Stella with David Wayne and Michael Showalter. And the other thing was the British office. I mean, mainly the British office. So I had been a huge fan since the British office. So for me, it felt very like full circle and neat for me personally, just to like get to be on the show. Yeah, so that was it.
I mean, it was not a lot of deliberation or anything. I was like, of course, I would love to be on the office. What a great phone call to get to be on the show. Yeah, so that was it. I mean, it was not a lot of deliberation or anything. I was like, of course, I would love to be on The Office. What a great phone call to get. Yeah, yeah. I haven't had a phone call that good in a while. Yeah, that was a good one. How did they talk to you about the character you would be playing?
Were you part of the development of this character? Did they tell you at the time, oh, you're gonna be paired with this other new guy? Did they give you any of those details? I knew we were going to be paired with another new guy. As far as like, you know, the characterization, I don't recall there being a lot of specific notes about like how to play. I mean, I think it was sort of like... Like do your thing?
Yeah, I think it was sort of like acting as casting, you know what I mean? I think it was just like kind of me. And I mean that was why, you know, because a lot of people said like, oh, like did they want to name you Clark? And like that was my idea and it was sort of also in the back of my head too, like maybe this is Clark from Clark and Michael, like like ten years later or whatever. Yeah. And I mean that was that was just like the lore in my head, like not like you know anybody else. But I also thought it was fun you know because there's a lot of people on the show that use their real name. Right. I don't think there was a lot of specific like you need to
play it like this. It was more like I think they kind of just wanted my you know me whatever that is. I have one more like follow-up question to your casting process. At the time, weren't you told that this could possibly be the beginning of a spin-off show? Like that you and Jake were gonna be the two new guys for the final season of The Office and that your characters might carry the torch into the next iteration? Yeah, that was my understanding of it.
Not even like a spinoff, but like ER, where it was like just new cast, some of the existing cast would stay and then you'd bring in like new people too and kind of be a mix. But yeah, that was my understanding of it, was it would be, yeah, like ER, and they would keep the show going.
So I was looking forward to being on the show for like years, potentially. I remember when we watched the finale there was all of this extra footage, right you and With Dakota Johnson. Yeah, and like you were gonna be each other's love interest We shot like this whole I remember for like a week or two. Yeah, we shot all this stuff There's tons of footage. Yeah all gone. I wonder if they'll put it back in the superfan episode Maybe maybe well It was so funny too because I'm I saw like or somebody sent it to me on Instagram a while ago when she was doing The press for a for a movie she kept talking about how
Like oh that was like the worst week of my life like these I sit around and then they never use any of it Which made me laugh really hard. Well Dakota it might be in the super fan. It might come back. It might live again But yeah, but that was um Yeah, that was my understanding of it in my hope you know to be honest well we have a fan question great for you from Joanne Kay in Cape May New Jersey she says what was it like coming into the office so late in the run it seems like it would feel like being a transfer student senior year it was a little bit like that but you know the thing is it wasn't hard because it was such a like smooth running machine.
You know you're joining like this thing that that like runs like a clock at that point. And everybody was so nice. And I will say you guys specifically you two were the nicest of and I'm not just saying that because of the podcast. You guys were very sweet to me. I always appreciate it. We were very excited when you and Jay joined the show. When we spoke with him, we told him that it was like,
we needed new people. Yeah. You guys were so funny. You were so nice. You were so talented. You had new stories to tell. I think that's the thing too. We were like a family where as soon as John started doing a bit, I'm like, that's the thing too is like we were like a family where like as soon as John started
doing a bit I'm like that's his boom operator bit. We've seen it for nine years. It's still funny but you guys came in with all this new energy. Well it is very much like a family because I mean when you you know just from doing so much tv over the years over the course of my life like you know you spend more time with those people on set than you do your actual family in a lot of cases, you know, for like six or nine months a year, like 12 or 14 hours a day. It is really like a family atmosphere. So yeah, it was sort of, I thought it was going to be intimidating, but it ended up being kind of just a pleasure because it was just so easy.
And everybody could go, you know? Like I remember, I think the first scene I ever shot was it was me and Rain at like the snack machine. Oh my gosh. And it was sort of like a feeling out thing of like, cause I wasn't sure how much, you know, like how much improv to do. Like you didn't want to show up and be like. That guy, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You don't want to like come in super hot. Be like, I got jokes guys. I know you've won some Emmys, but hey, here's my stuff. And you know, like, it never needed a lot of improv because the scripts were so good too. But I remember, you know, being a little bit nervous like that day. But then it was just, you know, Rain is so funny
and me and him had a good, I felt like had good chemistry together too. So that was so easy. I can't believe that was your first scene. I'm pretty sure, yeah. You guys cracked up a lot and it's in the bloopers. Yeah. I actually was gonna play it. Ready? Are you ready? This is, you guys are so tickled. So, all right, here we go. Want a coffee? No, I'll probably just just finish the bag of chips. You want a soda? Again, you don't have to give me stuff.
I appreciate it though. I got some noodles in my car. Sorry, I'm cracking myself up. I got some noodles in my car. So we could just... Just go get in your car? I got some noodles in my car, we could just hang out and have some noodles. Zane, if you're more hungry, I got a big tub of noodles in my car.
Just get it out. This goes on. Super professional. This goes on for a few minutes. Literally every time you said, I got some noodles, you guys would start breaking. Well, we basically just met. Yeah, that is so fun though. You could already see the chemistry between the two characters.
Yeah, the hardest I've ever laughed and the one that's still like, if I catch it on TV, like I'm, I don't know if you guys know this, but the show airs a lot on cable. It does. So I see, yeah see like on Comedy Central and every channel. It seems to be on every channel. It's on a loop. But if I ever see the one where
we're trying to move Stanley's body. Down the stairs. Down the stairs. Stairmageddon. That to me, like I like, even like shooting, I could not hold it together. I was like, this is the funniest, like when this head launches into the wall. Into the wall. Oh my gosh. But that was the great thing about the show
and about mockumentary is the formula and the format of the show being so grounded with the mockumentary you can get away with really big broad stuff Because I was like at first I was like this is really silly like I don't know if this is gonna work at all But then you watch it and it totally works because like the you know the mockumentary thing grounds it But yeah that that was that's I still think about that laugh, just trying to shoot that and get through it, because nobody could keep it together. I love that you brought that up, because I feel like we were afraid to do that mix
of a broad concept, but keeping it in the mockumentary world. And it was Mindy's episode, The Injury, where Michael grills his foot, which is just such like a broad ridiculous idea. And after that episode worked, I felt like that was the writers were like, Oh, okay. Yeah. Okay. We see what we can do here. Meredith can have a bat attack her head. Yes. Or get hit by Michael's car. It really does though.
It gives you a lot of freedom because I mean even think of the spinal tap. Yes. You know, like it's, yeah. That's the great, that's the thing that I love about my documentary. I've really got to do it twice because it doesn't come up a lot. Like I did it in Clark and Michael and then did it in the office. But yeah, I'd love to do more twice because it doesn't come up a lot. Like I did it in Clark and Michael and then did it in the office. But yeah, I'd love to do more mockumentary. Well, you're a writer director now.
That's true. Would you ever go that route? I actually have a script I'm working on right now that I would like to try to shoot this year that's a mockumentary, yeah. But I don't know if I'm gonna be in it. But yeah, definitely. Just because I miss, I miss, like it's such,
and it's such a fun way to shoot too. You know, you can move so fast. Like that was the other crazy thing about the office is how it felt like we shot a ton of pages a day. We did. Yeah, we did. Yeah, like compared to other stuff, like. So much, like yeah, like I'll.
Like 10 or 12 plus pages a day, which is a lot. I mean, I don't know if like people know like. twelve plus pages a day which is a lot I mean I don't know if like people know like that's a lot a lot of pages Yeah, a lot of pages and also, you know, we didn't move our lighting once we were in that main bullpen So we didn't have to wait for a lot of set up so we could move really quickly Which was great because as an actor you you kept the energy up Yeah, totally you wouldn't have that sort of slump as they would take forever to light. But I remember after being on the office and going through like 10, 12 pages a day, going to shoot a movie and I would look at the call sheet and I'd be like, we're doing seven eighths of a page today. Yeah. Like one or two pages. Yeah. Yeah. I'm
like, oh, okay. Yeah. It's a lot of sitting around. We're going to do this one page for 12 hours as opposed to 12 pages in 12 hours. It's great as an actor. I mean the Machiavellian thing too because you're shooting with you know two or three cameras usually at all times too so you can you know kind of like a Robert Altman thing like talk over each other and not have to worry about that and yeah I love that. Yeah. Well looking back on The Office is there a particular moment or episode that stands out to you as one of your favorites? I mean, Stare McGeddon.
I already answered this one, but that episode, and the first one, the first one where you meet us, you know, was obviously a really special thing for me. Well, you know what? The one where Dwight takes me on the sales call when we go to the father-son... Is that Suit Warehouse? Yes. Yes. It's so good.
That episode is so good. That might have been, that was a really fun one to shoot for me just because the stuff with Ryan was so fun. I mean the most surreal one or the one that like maybe sticks out the most was um the finale just because that was a little surreal. Like talk about the like transferring like senior year somewhere like and me and Jake Lacey have talked about this like it was it was kind of surreal because you know you guys had all been together so long and everybody's like crying and hugging. We kind of felt like two guys like standing around like
you feel kind of like you feel a little like like weird like like you're at like the funeral of someone like you just like. Should I go hug you? What do I do? Like an acquaintances funeral you know. know? So that was the most surreal thing probably. But yeah, funniest one is Sarah McGeddon for me. Like just could not keep it together. And then yeah, the first episode of that season where they introduce us. And then yeah, probably the Suit Warehouse. Well, you have one of my favorite talking heads.
It's when Clark is talking about his weekend with Jan. And it's one of my absolute favorites, and I want to play it. OK. Hey, guys. Clark, hey. Hey, look who's back. Dwight Jr.
Hey, so how was it? I mean, the sex with Jan. A gentleman doesn't discuss such matters, especially when the feelings of a lady are involved. Women reached their sexual peak at whatever age Jan was last week. I mean, it was like making love with a wild animal. But not like a cougar, like you might think.
It was like a swarm of bees. Bees that just find something wrong with every hotel room. That is so good! Your delivery is so great. Yeah, I did not write that line. I wish I did. That's excellent. That was a funny storyline in general. Because I think, if I remember right, I think that was sort of, the me and Jan thing was sort of written in because I had to go shoot a movie.
And it was one of those deals where I was committed to that before I came on the show, so we had to carve it out type of deal. I think that was why the Jan thing was how they wrote me off. But yeah, what a great, funny way to do it for like three weeks. Do you have any offset behind the scenes memories when you look back at that time on the office,
what do you think of? I mean, it was, I don't know, it was an interesting time. I like, I mean, I'm trying to think of stuff that would not be interesting to talk about. Cause I mean, for me, it's like, I think about, you know, like it felt like kind of a transitional moment in my life. Like I was moving, like I literally just moved from, so where they tape here, the podcast,
I used to live across the street in this building and I had moved out of there and was like living in this, like this house I rented and yeah we should share with everyone when you walked in you're like oh my gosh from the windows where we record he can literally see the window of his apartment yeah I can see my old apartment across the street here yes I don't know so for me it was an interesting it was it was such a fun weird kind of year because it was like you know just being on the show felt like this fun gift
that was just put in my lap that I got to do for a year. So it was just kind of pure joy, because I mean, you know, like I said earlier, a lot of shows are not that fun to shoot. I mean, especially now that everything is kind of just like, a lot of TV shows now are like movies that never end, like single camera stuff. It's like, you know, you can go shoot a movie
for like two or three months and do like the crazy hours because it's only for like, you know, a couple of months. But doing that like nine months a year, like really like wears on you after a while. Yeah. So yeah, it was such a fun year. You know, the main thing that kind of took me back because I'd never done,
I had never done a show that did that many episodes a year. And so it was really interesting for me just to watch the kind of ebbs and flows of like, everybody's got so much energy, you know, at first. And then by like, I remember there's like a hiatus, like midway through, and it's like, you need it because everyone's about to die, you know, from exhaustion. And then it was like the scripts after that, like in everybody's energy, like, OK, everybody's got way more energy again, you know, from like exhaustion. And then it was like the scripts after that, like in everybody's energy, like, okay, everybody's got way more energy again, you know, to kind of like carry you through. It was interesting for me just to watch the sort of endurance and the kind of rhythm of the thing and how you had to kind of pace yourself a little bit.
And also just how fast stuff would come out. Like we would shoot an episode and it'd be on TV, like, was it like two or three weeks later? Like really fast. Yeah, the turnaround was really quick. Yeah, the turnaround blew my mind. Yeah. Because I'd also never built anything that turned around that fast before.
Well, we'd get a script and we'd read it midweek and then we'd shoot it the next week. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah, I think for me just the process of it was really interesting to watch as far as the offsets. I guess that's still on set, but that was cool to me. I mean, one thing that I, you know, liked about the show so much, it was so excited about when I initially got the offer was the idea of, you know,
eventually being like like B.J. or Mindy and being like a writer producer kind of role in the show, too. And it went on longer. I'm so curious because, you know, over in the little accounting nook, we had our different bits that we would do with one another. Did you and Jake back in the annex, like sitting across from each other, did you have like bits that you did? Um, did you have the Zen garden? No. Remember how there was that that little sand Zen garden that left? Oh, I know. I don't recall it was Zen Garden.
Yeah, it used to be back in the annex. I don't think we did, because you know, weirdly, we didn't film, it feels like we didn't film a whole lot of stuff back there. Like I remember filming way more stuff with you than I do back there. But I mean, Paul would always crack me up. Yeah. Paul makes me laugh really hard. I ended up doing a, Paul directed a movie that I was in
a few years after called Song and That Come Back. Oh right. Yeah. And then we did during, Paul called me during like the lockdown part of COVID and I ended up doing this, it was like an audible middle space. Yeah. Yeah, it's great. It's so funny. Yeah. But it was so, that was then that most surreal part of like COVID in LA where, so they delivered like a sound booth to my house.
And like I built this like, they sent like a kit. They didn't even build, this is like what nobody would even like, like. Come in your house. No, no, it was like, we're gonna drop this giant refrigerator size thing outside like in your driveway. And so I builtsized thing outside, like, in your driveway. And so I built this thing of, like, PVC pipe in my garage.
You built it? Well, I mean, it's like... It's like Legos? Yeah, yeah. It's not that elaborate. I don't want to oversell, like, yeah. It had, like, instructions and, you know, it's literally just like PVC pipe. But still, you basically had to do an Ikea build.
Yeah, yeah. Exactly. You had to do an Ikea build of this thing and build a little like soundproof booth with the blanket over it and the whole thing and the mic and the stand and yeah. Sounds crazy. I was going to ask you if you took anything from the set when we wrapped because Jenna and I took a bunch of stuff. I took a bunch of shirts and a couple ties. You did? For your real life? Like that you would wear in your real life?
Well, I could, but I really don't. It was more keepsakes. It was, yeah. That was my question. Because I didn't really have any other props to speak of. You know what I mean? Because I never had a desk I'd been at for a long time or anything.
I took this very specific tie. Because I feel like I only had like two or three ties that rotated a lot, which was one thing that I liked about the show is it was kind of a real thing is you'd see clothes repeat. Yeah. Because you know, normally on TV shows, you'll like never see the same outfit.
Same outfit ever again. But I had like two or three ties, so I have one or two of those, and one that I see those on TV all the time, and it cracks me up. Oh, I love that. You mentioned how you didn't really have a desk, necessarily, so much that you sat out a lot.
And that reminded me of one of my favorite episodes, which is when you won't leave Jim's desk when he comes back. Yes. And your showdown with him is so good. It's really good. I love it. You're like, oh, because I'm here to sell paper.
Yeah. I would love to sit by my wife. All business. Yeah. Do you still get recognized from your time on the show? Oh my God. To a degree that like blows my mind. Only because I was only on the show for the one season.
But no, the office is like, I mean, it's like, I don't know, I've never been a part of anything like this big, you know, like now with like, it feels like it's so much bigger now than when the show was on too. Oh yeah. Like with like the conventions. I mean, there's people, I know people that are,
people come up to you and tell me this, that they just like watch the show on loop. I think it is bigger in a sense because there's all the people who watched it when it was originally on and now there are these additional generations who have found it and love it, but that first generation is also still watching it. So it's just this like cumulative fan base and it's... No, I would say like at least once a day, somebody in real life will say like, oh my
God, were you Clark from the office? Which is another reason to use your real name when you're on a TV show. Oh, it's good times, isn't it? I have this story that Jenna knows that I had lunch with Rain. We were leaving this little cafe and someone drove by and they yelled, Angela! And I was like, what? Oh, wait, sorry Rain, I might know them. And then they yelled, Dwight!
He goes, oh no, they yell your name. I was like, what? Oh wait, sorry, Rain, I might know them. And then they yelled, Dwight! He goes, oh no, they yell your name! I was like, they do, and every time I turn around and I think I might know someone. My favorite story that's similar to that is, after I had, this was like 2007 or something, I think the only thing I'd done was Clark and Michael and it was just on the internet. And I remember being at, we were at San Diego Comic-Con, like promoting some movie that hadn't come out yet, and somebody drove by in a car and yelled, internet! At me, which was one of my all-time favorite. But the weirdest thing is I turned around, I went like, I knew, I knew it was directed at me. Yeah.
That's pretty great. But no, like, no, the office thing is really like, like I said, it continues to blow my mind. But I mean, you're also, you know, it's so cool now with kind of, and I sort of knew this at the time, but even more now, like, you got to be part of one of the all-time shows.
I mean, this was like My Generation's Seinfeld, or Cheers, or you know. Yeah, just a classic show that everyone you knew watched at some point. Yeah, I remember one time Greg Daniels said something to me, and I'm going to paraphrase it and butcher it, but he said something along the lines of, in life you don't get that many
like really big bites at the apple. And like, you know, that was one of them for sure. Like that show. Yeah, yeah. I mean, Jenna and I definitely felt that when we started the podcast. We were like, well we don't want to get anything wrong because the show means so much to everyone.
And they will correct you. They will let you know, but they're always, they're very kind, I have to say. They are. They will say, ladies, that cold open actually was a tag and you got it wrong. Like, oh, sorry. Yeah.
I think it's because, you know, it's sort of that thing that like, I mean, the only thing I compare it to is like, you know, like Stern Show or something that you listen to like every day for hours on end. Like it almost, it feels like they're like Stern show or something that you listen to like every day for hours on end like it almost it feels like they're like your friends or family members and I mean I think people have like watched the show and lived with the show for so long now especially people that have watched it
like you know over like straight through over and over you know you feel like you know the people yeah and it feels like it feels like hanging out with friends I think well we did an entire re-watch of every single episode of the show. And you are a complete delight. You're a breath of fresh air when you come on in season nine. So funny.
I really enjoyed season nine. You and Jake were a big reason why. I had a blast. I thought, as just a viewer and a fan, I thought season nine was really strong in general. Agree. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I did too. Plus, I thought, as just a viewer and a fan, I thought season nine was really strong in general. Agreed. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I did too. Well, Clark, you have transitioned now into writing and directing and acting. You had your film Arkansas, which was based on a novel. It is an amazing mix of crime and dark humor and drama. Angela was very impressed by your cast. I really was.
I was looking at it on IMTV and I was like, holy moly. Liam Hemsworth, Michael Kenneth Williams, Vivica A. Fox, Eden Brolin, Chandler Duke, your brother, John Malkovich, and Vince Vaughn. Wow. What was it like working with that cast? It was great. I mean, it was sort of the same thing as The Office. It just makes your life as a director really easy.
Somebody said, oh, what was it like directing John Malkovich? I'm like, a director really easy. Like somebody said like, oh what was it like directing like John Malkovich? I'm like, it's really easy. He's John. John Malkovich. Yeah. He gets it. Yeah, he knows all of our lines. I'd look over and he'd be like putting a mat
over a loose cable and like, I mean. Helping the crew out. No, literally. He's just a delight. Yeah, I love John Malkovich. I still email with him every now and then Yeah, I mean it makes it just makes your life really easy like more than anything and again I mean, I think a lot of it just comes down to chemistry like I felt like me and Liam
Had a good like we had a good back and forth with each other And we were friends and have stayed friends Yeah, I mean that was that was what I you know I really I came out here to go to school to be a writer-director. Like that was really what I wanted to do more so than the acting. And then like, you know, kind of by virtue of being in Clark and Michael, kind of got the acting career and did that for a nice long time and had a blast. But I always, you know, I was always like making shorts and I was always writing. And like, I mean, I had the option to the book, Arkansas, for probably almost like a decade.
And then finally I was like, all right, you get to now or never. So it didn't feel, it doesn't feel like an abrupt change to me. Right, because it's always been part of you. Well, yeah, and I was always wanting to do it and kind of trying to do it. But it was hard because, I mean, thank God,
I got to work a lot as an actor. And that takes a lot of time up. But you know, like, it was hard because I, I mean, thank God, you know, I got to work a lot as an actor. And that takes a lot of time up, that's a full-time job. Yeah. So it was sort of a matter of like, after the last show was on, which Jake Lacey was also on, called I'm Dying Up Here on Showtime.
We also did this other TV show together. That's wild. Yeah. And now he's in your next movie. He is, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, me and Jake are on these parallel paths
with each other. Your third project. Yeah. But it was kind of like after that show, I'm Dying Up Here ended, I finally got to make Arkansas, which I'd been trying to make for a few years at that point. And to the degree that it had different producers
and a completely different cast, it went multiple points. And then somehow it just like, and so much of it is just scheduling and timing. Malkovich had a week in October or whatever. So it's like, all right. We gotta make it happen. It's like, all right, we're shooting in October. Yeah.
But it was, yeah after after that that show wrapped up I really just you know threw myself into that and worked on that for you know like a couple of years like making a movie takes a really long time. It does. Yeah. It really does. I remember when my husband and I, we made this indie, the giant mechanical man, like from our first meeting until it came out, we fell in love while we were making this movie, by the way. And so from that first time we met, where I was like, here's the pitch meeting where you're pitching me the movie
and I say yes, and then we go off, we're gonna try to get it made. We fell in love, we got married, I got pregnant and I had a baby. All of that happened before the movie came out. It was like five years. Yeah, no. And that's sadly, I mean, especially with independent movies, like that's kind of the norm. So yeah, like I said, I've been trying to make that movie for years and then spent two plus years or whatever making it. And then it finally came out right as COVID started.
Like the movie came out May of 2020. So that was like right when all the like, you know, lockdowns and everything started. So did you get to have the big premiere? No. Or anything? No. Was it in theaters? No.
No. We were going to be. Of course. We were going to be. We almost made it. Yeah. It would have been like the last independent film in theaters. Oh, man. No. As an artist, I know just because of how long it
takes to push the boulder up the mountain and then. Not to get to celebrate it in that big way. Yeah, it felt really anticlimactic. I mean, I didn't want to feel too, you know, like sorry for myself just because there was such like real life, you know, horror going on with everybody. For sure. But no, it's tough. It's kind of a tough pill to swallow because like you said, you spend like years and years
on it. But it ended up doing great on VOD. It was one of the first like, you know, like I feel like movies that got moved to VOD. So I think it felt like we were like, it was like us and like Sonic the Hedgehog like the only movies even available to watch type of thing. So we ended up doing really well. And yeah, now I'm in post right now on my second film
that me and my brother Chandler wrote, and he's in, he acts in this one too, and he was in Arkansas as well, but I'm not in this one. I just directed this one, but. What's it like to have a project like that with your brother? How do you guys work together? Yeah, do you have a ritual when you're writing?
A little bit. So it was sort of, you know, that was probably like one positive thing that came out of, you know, the kind of long quarantine of everybody is I had rented an office space literally like a month before all that started, like, and everybody got, you know, locked in their houses. I had rented an office space, literally like a month before all that started, like everybody got locked in their houses. I had rented these two offices. So me and my brother and his writing partner from college,
Billington, just started going there every day. And so, just to kind of keep from going crazy, and just have somewhere to go, and it still felt very safe. It's just the three of us, and we don't see anybody else. Like a second quarantine. A little bit, yeah, but it was at least
like a second location. So thank God, like, you know, we had that and we had each other to kind of like talk to, but we started going over there and we just started writing every day and we wrote, you know, over a couple of years, like, I don't know, like four or five or six movie scripts. So we got- Wow.
Yeah, so we have some material now and this is the first one. And then after all the lockdowns kind of died down, like this movie Stranglehold was going to get made, and then it was like gearing up, and then the strikes happened. So then we had to take another 18 months off or whatever. But anyway, we finally shot the thing, and now I'm starting, well not starting, we're on to the point now, we're on to the like the point now we're about to start the music you're in post-production we're in
post-production like most of the editing is done but now we got to do all the the color and sound and the music and all that all that kind of stuff but the movie will probably come out it's a Christmas movie I was gonna say can you tell us a little bit about it yeah I love a Christmas movie it's she loves a Christmas I'm very excited already. Can I come to the premiere? Yeah, there's a premiere. Yes, of course. I just confided myself.
I have a red plaid dress I can wear. Okay, go on. It's set at Christmas and it's about a stripper and her alcoholic veteran husband who decide to rob the strip club she works at at Christmas. Okay. So.
Merry Christmas! Yeah. Yeah. Who else in it? Ashley Benson and Jake Lacey. Oh, nice. Are they the couple? They're the couple.
Okay. Justin Long. Okay. Ron Perlman is the owner of the club and Justin plays his son, which is very funny. David Arquette is in the film, Brian Possein's in the film. Yeah, we got another great cast. Yeah, another great cast. So cool.
Yeah, but I am not in it. Did you like not being in it? Did you like, did you prefer? I wanted to try it. You wanted to try it. I wanted to try it. Yeah, is this your first film you've directed that you've not been in?
Well, I've only made the two, so yes. Well, and I guess. Well, but yeah, but even like Clark and Michael and all those. Yeah I was on all those too. Yeah you're right. So this is your first time strictly being behind the camera? It was. It was because now that I think about it even like the shorts and stuff I'd made over the years I was always with those too. So yeah it was. How'd you like it? It was a mix. I mean we had so few days like we shot the whole whole movie in like 17 or 18 days or so. So I mean, I couldn't have physically done it.
Right. Like I would have collapsed, you know. It was sort of more out of necessity. Because I did like the part that Justin played I wrote for myself, you know, initially, but it just became like a logistical thing. But I also wanted to try it and just see, you know, what the difference was and if I did feel like it improved anything. Honestly, I kind of miss being in it though.
I don't know. I think I might go, I don't know. I'm on the fence. It depends on what day you ask me. Yeah. I know. I always think about that too. I had written this short film one time and I was going to direct it and then I decided
no, I need someone else. I need that third eye. So my friend stepped in to direct it But then I kind of micromanaged him and I was also in it. So I don't think I could not be in it I think I want to do bits I want to be in there, you know The thing for me that I found on on Arkansas because I was you know, I was in like 80% of that movie But I kind of found a lot of times it was sort of just one less person to deal with
Like oh, it's kind of found a lot of times it was sort of just one less person to deal with like oh It's kind of like one person you don't have to direct and I mean like when you have really good actors That's sort of not much of an issue anyway But I was like, you know I knew what I wanted the character to kind of be and do and right I knew what I want the line-reading to be You know type of thing one less note to give yeah kind of so I didn't really mind it But I also didn't really know any different because I'd only ever acted in the stuff that I directed But so I don't know going forward. I would you know, I miss doing comedy Mm-hmm, like acting wise I miss doing comedy and they just don't make like theatrical like they don't they don't exist
Yeah, weird, right? It's very weird. Like I don't understand it because I know people I mean, I guess it just moved the TV But I miss um, I guess it just moved the TV, but I miss... I miss a good funny movie where you're laughing so hard. I know, and I was very blessed. I got to spend a bunch of years acting in those, and it was so fun. So I miss that. Yeah, that used to kind of be... There was always a couple. There were these big summer summer blockbuster comedy and there
were no superheroes in them. And there were no like giant car chases either. There were just like awesome jokes. And now those are exclusively... Exclusively I guess streaming? Theatrical releases or car chases and horror films. And like superheroes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know every you know everything cycles It does it does I was I was listening to I listed this podcast this film history show called you must remember this do you know the show no no But I'm writing it down very good. You know it'll just give you like a reminder of like how You know like the parallels between like in the 50s when television came along
and the studios were collapsing. There's a lot of parallels between that and now. It just is a reminder that everything cycles. Well, what will happen is someone will make a great comedy. It'll be an outlier and it'll hit big and then we'll go into the season of comedy again. I think we're doing something like that Yeah, I think we're due for like a whole new group of people a whole new like style account like, you know Cuz it kind of felt like you know
like I had like like one line in like super bad and it was like It feels like everyone in super bad got a career It felt like that was like a graduating class a little bit, you know And we're all still kind of still around. And I don't know like what the equivalent movie to that since then is. Like it felt like there was like a scene like UCB and like I don't know. Because I feel like it's like you said you've been around long enough, you know, like I feel like I still know and see like everybody from you know 20 years ago that whatever that was. I still like hang out
with my friends from Improv Olympic. So it's like that group you kind of come up together with. All right, Clark, it is time for our call sheet questions. Okay. What was your first entertainment job that you were paid for? I believe it was a commercial when I was like five or six years old.
Come on. It was either a commercial or it was, I did a pilot that Carrie Fisher wrote and produced and Debbie Reynolds starred in. What? When I was like six years old. Were you a child actor? Yes, yes.
What? I did not know this, did you know this? I did not know this. Yes. First of all, I need to back it up. My SAG card says like 1991 on it. Okay, wait. Yeah, that's not know this. Did you know this? I did not know this. First of all, I need to back it up. My SAG card says like 1991 on it. Okay, wait. Yeah. That's not a joke.
Okay. I need to- Member since 1991. I need you to back up. That's the year I graduated from high school. Yeah, well I was already, I already had a full-time job. You did? So. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I need to know. I have so many questions now. You were living in Arkansas, and you became a child actor in Arkansas. No. No. My mother had a childhood friend live in LA that we came and visited that was working as an actress. Okay.
And her manager saw me. It was like, this kid's gotta be in showbiz. We gotta get this kid out, we gotta send him out. And like sent me on, I think a commercial, I mean my mother can answer this better than I could because I was like five years old. But yeah, booked a bunch of commercials and then did- Do you remember then any of the commercials?
Like what were the products? Like Toyota, Kellogg's, there was a Pop Tarts and there were all like big national spots. Wow. Yeah, did that pilot and then CBS signed me to a holding deal. How old were you when you had a holding deal? Like six or seven, like something like that. How was that for you? Did you? It was fun. Like there was no pressure. There was no pressure. You're a child. Yeah. Yeah. Because I was I was a very like gregarious, you know, like, like talkative, like. But would you have to leave school to do these projects? And how was that socially? You were like the guy who was going to LA from Arkansas? Yeah, but I mean, you're like such a little kid.
I feel like it's before you're like... That's true. It's before anyone's really aware of it. It's before neurotic stuff sets in. Yeah, they're just like, Clark's back. Okay, hi, Clark. And then I ended up on um on the sitcom Called hearts of fire. This is John Ritter and Markie Post and Billy Bob Thornton and Ed Asner
Crazy cast and Billy Bob's also from Arkansas as most people probably know like the same place that I'm from and Did that for like three years and then after that, went back to school in Arkansas, because my mom, you know, wanted me to have a normal like school and childhood experience. And it was like she was insistent that I like go to school and go to college and all that stuff. So then, yeah, went through high school in Arkansas and then came back out here for college. Okay, wait. And then started working again. I have a question. So when you go back to school in Arkansas, do you still have that acting bug?
Like are you doing theater in high school? Are you doing the plays? I wasn't I did very much have like I knew I wanted to come back But I but I since I was about 12, I want I really I really wanted to be a movie director That was really what I always wanted to do and yeah Of course that was from you know being out here like because those were like, like thank God, like I don't have any like child actor horror stories. Like those were like really fun years for me. Like when I think back about like childhood and stuff like that, I have just like really fond,
you know, kind of bizarre memories. Oh man. That's so fascinating to me. So that was, yeah, that was one of my many lives I've lived. I mean, question number one. I know. Mind some goals there. Question number two, do you speak any other languages?
No. No. I wish. You can move on quickly on question number two. I took Spanish in high school and college, but it's like if you don't use it, you forget it. And I wish. Yeah.
Well, do you play a musical instrument? I can play guitar. Not like excellently or anything, but yeah, play guitar. Right. I had a phase when I lived in the building across the street, we DJed for a while, which was fun. I guess DJing is a type of instrument. It really was.
I mean, it was in the like, it was the last time there was kind of a real scene. It was right before like camera phones basically. Did you have a DJ name? Yeah actually me and my friend Chris Holmes who's still a huge DJ. He's a Paul McCartney's opening act. Oh my gosh. But we uh, we called ourselves Show Business. I thought that was pretty good. Business with an S or a Z? With an S. With an S. Show business taking the stage. We had a, Chris made business cards one time and they said show business
and then on the back it just said no requests. I thought that was funny. With no contact info either. Just that. Just that. Just that. What's a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved?
I mean, I've been a lot of places I liked. I really enjoyed getting to film in London, just because the, and getting to like live there for like an extended period, because I did all the touristy stuff, like the walking tours and all that, you know, like the Jack the Ripper historical walking tour, like I did all like with the group,
it's like me and the other group walking around with a little map. So that was pretty fun, because I mean, it's one thing, visit somewhere but to get to kind of live somewhere for a while. You know what was bizarre about that? When I left that season the office to do Kickass 2, that was in London and I was living at these furnished apartments like the Oakwood.
I don't know if people know what the Oakwood is. Well it's not even the Oakwood anymore. But you know what I mean. Yeah, it's just furnished apartments that a lot of people stay in when they're filming. Corporate housing. Yeah. Corporate housing. It's not even the Oakwood anymore, but you know what I mean. It's just furnished apartments that a lot of people stay in when they're filming. Corporate housing. And the only other person that I ever saw every day in the gym or the lobby was John Malkovich.
And we never spoke. How wild. I think I said hello to him. I'm pretty sure I told him this because that was years before I worked with him in Arkansas. But yeah, getting to spend a lot of time in London was really fun. Because I hate long flights, so I don't know if I'll... Like, I'm not somebody that travels for fun, because a 12-hour flight is my nightmare.
And I feel like I spent so many years traveling for work a lot. Which was great, because you get to see a lot of places. You get to work in Miami and Atlanta and Vancouver and Toronto and London. I don't know when the next time I'll get back over there is. So I'm happy that I got to, that someone paid me to go on an extended vacation over there was pretty good. It's such a special place. Jenna lived there too for a job. I did. And it's one of my favorite memories too. Cause it's like you said, I really-
The city's like 2000 years old. It's just cool. I mean, amazing. And also there's little things about like, I do love to travel, but I like to stay places as long as possible so I can do things like, what's their grocery store like? No, totally. I agree. You know, like how do they sell their fruit here? I love details like that. The day to day. I remember, Joa left me a message one time while she was over there, we would leave each other messages and she was like,
well, today I went to buy a microwave. Yeah. And you had it, like, was it a book? Well, it was very strange. I had to purchase a microwave for the flat that I was renting and the store, you walked in and there was just a guy behind the counter and then there were like three catalogs.
There weren't items out. No items, and then you would point to it, and he would go like deep in the back, bowels of beyond this door behind the counter, and then he would come back with the microwave. It was like- It's like when you order food and they have the picture. Yes. Yes.
Or if like Amazon was a store. Was just a dude. And you just like pointed and then they brought it out to you. It was so interesting. And that was when I asked the production, where does one go to buy, how do you buy a microwave here?
They're like, oh, you go to this. Catalog man. Yeah, catalog man. She left me that message years ago. I think about it all the time. I don't know why, but it really stuck with me. Well, another thing was they don't do drip coffee, like a drip coffee maker,
where you just make like 12 cups of coffee at once. And I wanted one and I asked them, where does one get a drip coffee maker? Catalog guy didn't know what I was talking about. Everybody was like, what is this machine you speak of? Cause they just do like pour over French press. They make one great cup of coffee in the morning. And then they drink their tea.
And you're like, I need 12 cups. I'm like, I know I'm like, want to make 12 at a time. I'm American. I want a thermos of coffee. Yes, I want tons of coffee all the time. So they had assigned me a driver for the show and they said he could also help me get settled. And I remember one day, I'll never forget it.
Oh man, I love this guy so much. He pulled up and he had the big smile on his face and he was holding a drip coffee maker in a box because that was the other thing, like it has to have the right plug, you know? It has to go in their outlet so I couldn't just bring mine. I guess I could have done a converter but then, I don't know, I was worried I'm gonna start a fire. So I, so he found one, he found one and when we got to set,
he was so excited, He read the directions. He set it up in my trailer. I made us a pot of coffee, shared a cup of coffee with him. He was like, he'd never seen it before. He's like, this was $1,200. This coffee maker. I drove five hours to get it. It was also, you guys, it was also red. It was red. It was like shiny red KitchenAid mixer, but it was a drip coffee maker. And how happy were you to have it?
So happy to have it. Do you still have it? I don't because when the show ended, they took all the things that I had bought for my apartment and they put it in storage for me and then the show got canceled and they said what do you want us to do with all this stuff? And it was like well they had given me a budget to buy most of it so I thought well I don't need it and they said well
what we could do is we could put it out. We could just let the crew take whatever they want. And I said, that's fine, but you need to give my driver two things before you put everything out. One is that coffee maker. I just want him to have it. Oh, that's nice. And also the TV that I bought, because he carried it up four flights of stairs for me.
So he gets both those things, and then everybody can have anything else. I bet every time people come over to his house and they see the TV, he's like, you know whose TV that is, right? Maybe. Like John Voight Spencil on Seinfeld, you know? Yeah.
This is like somebody, like that show, that other show, Me and J. Cron, I'm Dying Up Here, Robert Forster. The, Robert Forster. The great Robert Forster. I had the pleasure of knowing him. Oh, then you probably have this also. He gave us all letter openers. Do you have the Robert Forster letter opener?
No, I never worked with him. I knew him like as a friend. He would come, he and I would both lecture to acting students and he had this great spiel that he would do. And so that's I knew him through a mutual friend and we would speak to aspiring actors and he is a gem. He was awesome. Great story. Jackie Brown is one of my favorite movies.
Same. Yeah. And you have the letter. He gave us each, each of the cast members, he gave us each a, this nice little box and you open it up as this beautiful silver letter opener. And I use this thing every day. Yeah. And every time I see it, I start, and if anybody ever sees it,
I tell them, you know, it's Robert Forster's letter opener. It's like, it's like John Boyd's pencil in George's car. Totally. But apparently he gave these to literally, I mean, he said this, he's like, I give these to everyone that I work with. So like I've met other people that like worked with them and they're like, oh yeah, I got the letter opener. It's like his thing. It was his thing. He had this guy. That's classy. I want to get a thing. Is it too late? Is it too late? I want to get a thing too.
I know, I want a thing too. It's so classy. I just turned 50 and I think 50 is when you get a thing that you then do, because otherwise it might be, it might be condescending if you're like 23 and you're like, here's your gift for working with me. Right? That's pretty ballsy though. Once you're older, you can hand out a thing.
Oh, totally, yeah. After they work with you. Oh, I'm starting that. I don't know what I'm giving away but I'm gonna start it. I want to do it with you. I thought we have to do different things though. Yeah we'll come up with something. Yeah I don't know what it should be but I thought the letter opener was such a like classy thing because it's you know it looks nice it's silver it's beautiful and it's so functional. Yeah. You use well I mean I'm saying it's so functional like the kids watching the TikTok are not opening
letters but they'll get bills. They don't know what paper mail is. They don't know what paper mail is, yeah. Again, for the listeners, this is Clark, I am 75 years old. And that means Jenna and I are dot, dot, dot. Okay, we have two more call sheet questions for you. Here they are.
Number four, what do you like to do on the weekends? I don't know that my weekend activities that much different from my weekday activity because I don't have like a nine to five, you know? Yeah. Like I like to go to the comic store. Like with the comic book store and you physically hold all the comic books.
I love that I used to be into comics. I like to go to the comic store rummage around. Yeah. Do you have one that's like your favorite store? My favorite is House of Secrets in Burbank. That's my favorite one. And it's partially my favorite because I literally went there as a child when I was a child actor. So it's got, you know, the nice nostalgia for me. Plus it's also just an excellently ran store Guys that run under are very nice. What's your favorite series? All-time like uncanny x-men like the prime like 1980s Chris Claremont uncanny x-men
That's that's pretty tough to beat. I think that's like a seminal thing for like so many like Creative people my age like that and Watchmen yeah those are those are the two I feel like those are the two biggest like because like like the old you know the 80s X-Men I think is basically like the template of kind of like what like Buffy the Vampire Slayer was like that kind of formula like I feel like it kind of went out and had a much bigger you know impact than people realize did you ever get get into the comedic,
autobiographical comics? Yeah, like Arkrum and Peter Panhagen, that kind of stuff. Or like Joe Matt or whoever. Yeah, totally, totally. But I mean, for me, the childhood thing was definitely like the X-Men and the Spider-Man and the superhero stuff. But no, there's really great work being done now in comics yeah all right final question Angela all right
Clark what is your favorite midnight snack? ooh I think my favorite midnight snack is probably it's either fruity pebbles or the cocoa pebbles you like a little cereal a little cereal and I specifically like those two. I like the Post brand cereals. Did you do commercials for them? No. Oh no.
No, just Kellogg's. But I love the two Flintstones branded cereals. Milk. The Rice Krispie versions are good too, the Cocoa Krispies are also good. Oh yeah, I do full milk. They're fantastic, yeah. This is another, I am 75 years old, I still buy milk, like regular milk. do full milk. This is another like, I am 75 years old,
I still buy milk, like regular milk. No fancy milk. No, none of these fake milks. Give me the real deal. Full f***ing milk. I see a milk commercial in your future. Not even like 2%, I want the whole. The whole, yeah.
Well Clark, thank you so much. Thank you guys. Thank you. It's so nice to see you. Come and buy it, hanging out with us today. This was a pleasure. Yeah. Thank you. It's so nice to see you. Come and buy it. Hanging out with us today. This was a pleasure. Yeah.
This is super fun. So wonderful to see you. By the way, your email that you sent back, oh my God, this is great. This is so funny. Wait, we have to tell. Yeah, I should tell this. So when I was, when my first movie, Arkansas, the first movie I directed was coming out, it was in the midst of all the COVID stuff.
And so I texted and emailed all the people I knew that had big Instagram or social media following. So I was like, hey, I'm just trying to get the word out, people who watch this movie. And I sent this email, I sent it to you, amongst a bunch of other people I know. And you emailed me, you responded to the email like a month ago? Yeah.
And the emails from- No, like two months ago. The emails from 2020. 2020. Yeah. And I went, I was like looking for your email. God, I don't know, maybe to my spam or whatever. But I was like, oh my God, Clark. I go, this is great about your movie.
It's so sorry I missed it. And then I was like, do you want to come on the podcast? I'm so sorry. And this is like one of the things Jenna knows, And then I was like, do you want to come on the podcast? I'm so sorry. And this is like one of the things Jenna knows, like Sam and Cassie, they all know that my inbox, unusual, says about, I don't know what's it say today, 3,814.
Oh, that physically hurt me just now. I know. I have to zero mine out. I do as well. I have to have it, I have to zero it. I cannot. That would give me... I have whittled that down. You would not believe. I wouldn't be able to function. What's in there? Is it just like from like Michaels? Like $5 coupons from Michaels and home goods and stuff? Exactly. Yes. And I need to go through it. But anyway,
so I missed your email. But now I've put little. But the fact that you did, the funny thing is you didn't send a new email. You responded to that one. That was what I love. Clark, so sorry, I missed this. Oh my God. I was doing like, I was trying to open up emails I hadn't opened up. I know, it was so ridiculous.
Do you worry you may have missed like other, like way more important emails? I'm sure I have. I'm sure I have. I just have to let it go. It doesn't keep me up at night at all. It keeps me up at night. It bothers Jenna.
I wouldn't be able to function. In our business partnership over this last five years, Angela has had to create so many strategies to open email. And I've said to her too, I've said like, how do I contact you? Like most reliably. Text me.
Are you better on text? Yes. I'm so much better on text. Noted. But I'll send her an email, but I mean sometimes you can't, an email is necessary for business. So I will send her an email
and then I will text her and say, I just sent you an email. I'll tell you what you need. You need to get a fax machine. I'd love a fax because I would hear it Like the bat phone This serious, but I have it's either a doctor's office Yeah, either way kids school. Yeah, either way serious I did create all these little folders now and I you can tell the folder what emails to put in it And so I have my business folder
So I that only has like 12 emails since she did that she's been a different person business wise I think you should think about the facts though. I can't say personal email-wise but business-wise. I think you guys should buy two fax machines. One for your house, one for your house. I kind of want to do this. I do too. I would. If you get one, I'll get one. You have to get a landline. I have a landline. It's my passion. You guys, I had a landline and then my husband was like we never use the landline I should get it back. I'm not getting rid of mine. Never. It's like the physical newspaper I'm gonna try to enjoy it as long as we can. I get the physical newspaper Wait, are you Jenna has the landline because she's worried about like a zombie apocalypse and that way she will have a landline Hey, I mean when when the fires hit,
the first thing I did was get out my little boop boop boop boop boop boop phone and plug it in the wall. Yep. Because I was like, if I need to alert someone of this exact place, I'm calling 911, and they immediately know your address. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't know. It's basically free with my cable and internet, too I think it's like ten more dollars a month or something Alright, so if we each get a fax machine, I'll fax you guys. Yeah. Oh my god We can send each other like the gag faxes, you know, like the funny drawings. Uh-huh memes basically memes Oh the first name really was that really was the original Yeah, oh, well well this was a delight.
Yeah. Clark, thanks so much. Thank you so much. My pleasure. Email me when your movie comes out. Fax her. Text me. I'll just come over here.
All right, you know where we are now. Well, that was absolutely amazing. And were we right about the call sheet questions? Clark is so interesting. He's so layered. And were we right about the call sheet questions? Clark is so interesting. He's so layered. Oh my goodness. Well, thank you all for writing in your questions and comments. And thank you, Clark, for coming in the studio today.
Yeah. I am really loving having these sit down one-on-ones with the cast members of the office. Yeah. And getting to reconnect. Yeah. Now we're going to get fax machines. So we're going to be in touch all the time. We hope you guys have a great week.
See you soon. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.